[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you okay
you see
you
the scooter is you're ruining the city
you think you're so cool huh you're so
hip scooting around the wind in your
hair not a care in the world
give me that sorry i just did a story i
just get a secret sorry come on
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god my worst nightmare how do you
think i feel i am living this right now
robot made out of scooters so is that
like a bad thing scooters ruined my life
they're the worst i was gonna say the
worst because they are stupid stupid and
awful awful disgusting oh i hate
scooters so much
i do not know what to do with all of
these feelings
i'll show you what you can do
[Music]
pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
wow
this place is so cool ooh what does that
do
mixed up hot what's this for pee pee
who are they friends
what's that pizza what are those beer
what is all this this
is dinner
dinner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
can we do dinner again tomorrow i mean
yeah it's uh kind of an everyday thing
scooty you do this every day yeah you
don't come on breakfast lunch
sometimes brunch crunch best parts of
breakfast
best parts of lunch
[Music]
brunch oh my god can we do that i mean
yeah tomorrow
sure
yay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did the scooters ruin your life huh
in the alley you said scooters ruined
your life
we were a team of champions
we were to wield transit with the
beatles for a rock and roll
except when we rolled
[Music]
we stuck together
[Music]
you're so i thought
byron why don't you show us how these
bad batteries work
[Music]
would you look at that photo anyone can
do it
this is incredible what are you guys
doing have you seen these no
no this is not us we're not doing this
this is stupid
get away
anyway
that's why i hate scooters but you don't
hate me
right
no you're
you're scooty
not some inanimate object
everyone else probably hates you though
well these
how do i make them not hate me
come with me
so people hate you because you're a
scooter right
um well they do okay but that's just
because i think you're this dumb stupid
lifeless soulless chunk of junk
so show them what you're not
[Music]
wow
what is this jake you could call it a
[Music]
heist and we are back with the ceo
himself and founder byron scott why
don't you tell us more about this big
black box here what does it do it's next
generation server hardware costing only
20 entire core traffic how to get back
to uh
it sounds too good to be true scooty has
transferred all of its server data over
to this one singular unit incredible but
what about scooty's user data risk if
there's a power outage someone carries
it out the building gps uh backup
the only way this thing is going down is
if you sink into the bottom of the
pacific ocean
incredible
right
way okay okay so we get the box put it
in the plane fly it over the ocean drop
it
no more scooters fly just throw it off
the pier
he's in the middle of the pacific ocean
yeah it sounds fun definitely but you
know there's other fun stuff we can do
for example
brunch i am not going out for brunch
with you bro i mean look at the tv they
get the [ __ ] out of us
that's
it's not fair
i know
so let's make it right
we get rid of the scooters
i get my friends back and
people don't hate you
we could get brunch hold on are you
manipulating me
no
okay let's do it yes
[Music]
do you take venmo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
david
uh
you need to take these uh faulty
scooters up to the uh
the maintenance floor the server floor
for maintenance those are gonna go
straight to the scooter scorcher the
scooter
sculpture the incinerator
oh uh
so what's good bro
do you need a recycle yeah just some
some stupid scuba scraps uh what
happened
struck by lightning
oh i know this is so exciting
i know
stay cool
let's go
[Music]
you bust in get the card and i'll turn
off the cameras okay okay one
two
[Music]
three
hey
hey
you said you could be down here oh scoot
i'm just going to
put the scooter deposits for you
let me help you with that oh no that's
fine that's fine there's a white male
and
it's totally good
you know what i got this
you sure yeah thank you though okay
don't do anything funny okay no no
all right
we're gonna get me out of here i'm
slipping [ __ ] the door's closing just
hold on no one i'm gonna fall out for
like five seconds
please i'm serious
[Music]
[Music]
hello
anybody
help me
jake
no this is zoey hi zoe how did you get
in there okay it's kind of long story
yesterday i was born
and he just left you down there no he
was gonna come back for me honestly this
guy sounds like such an [ __ ] no it's
it's not like that
what do you say we get you out of there
and we go get some coffee
[Music]
i'm taking this in for uh maintenance
[Music]
i almost died in there oh don't be
dramatic give me the keys no here's
what's gonna happen okay i'm taking that
i'm finishing this heist and then i can
hang out with the people that actually
want to get coffee with me whatever that
is
here are your stupid rollerblades
they're tacky anyway
i really wanted to be your friend
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
everyone out of the way i don't think i
can stop this
thank you
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jake scooty i'm sorry
i'm so sorry i should have never left
you back there
i was
stupid stupid
and awful awful
and you are my friend my only one
and it may not be much
but you're my best friend
[Music]
here we go baby
[Music]
jake
what what's gonna happen to me
scooty you were struck by lightning
you'll be fine okay i promise you don't
know that i mean like maybe we could
just do some research before seriously i
just hung off the side of a plane for
you
god you were so what
what am i jake
so right
really
we can do this anytime
but we only have an hour left until
lunch
you don't mean that's exactly what i
mean
what do you say you and me go get some
[Music]
i got you
i'm fine i'm absolutely fine
i hate you
sure you do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you